hold on
i don't belong in this sleeping society
you're all responsible for your illegal
wars you ignore the screams and the
cries of the countless lives you take
i realize the actions i must take from
my people
this is the consequence of your
ignorance if you won't stop
attacking us in our lands then don't be
surprised when we attack you
in yours
hold on doesn't the quran teach you to
call to the way of your lord with wisdom
and beautiful preaching
what wisdom is saying taking my life and
the lies of others
this isn't the beautiful message of
islam nor are my actions backed by the
teachings of the quran
if you take the life of a single soul
it's like taking the life of the whole
of mankind
if you save the life of a single soul
it's like saving the life
of the whole of mankind
hey mister you forgot your bag
be careful won't you bye
a muslim is he with whose speech and
hands the people are safe
and a believer is he with who the lives
and the wealth of the people is trusted
terrorism has no religion
you